sandi Wexler this movie is based on a
great figure in show business a real
figure sandy Warnock who was represented
you for a long time yes and you weren't
any other yeah and he's always here with
us right now sandy warnings over there
in the corner there he is
you've been you've been doing an
impression of sandy for years and making
fun of him and then you finally decided
screw it yeah this is a movie and you
made this movie which is very funny by
the way thank you yeah yes you my you
mock him just as much as I don't think I
do but yes I do
yeah when we told sandy yeah we were
making a movie about him he told his
friends and stuff and they're like
they're doing you when he's like yeah
they go they're gonna do this stupid
voice to Sandy's again and then I think
gonna have you eat like an animal with
food on your face yeah is he gonna lie a
lot like you do yeah sad no so here's
the deal
call everybody honestly this guy sandy
is like he's like my family and I love
more than anything and he's a very sweet
guy very good guy he's a great man and
he's been with me since I'm a young boy
but anyways I wanted to tell the story
where it was insane so yeah so I'm
writing he doesn't always have the best
decisions or advice not every time not
every well we land on our feet sandy
right buddy thank you thank you so sandy
can't speak by the way unless he's
getting paid go ahead
yes so okay so we're going it's like 20
years ago what you're having - I think
the Today Show or Good Morning America
well just a show a morning show we're in
the car we're driving in New York City
you know how you make the rounds got a
movie coming out so we're pulling up the
street I see a bunch of guys on the
street we'd pick it sighs the whole
sides and I was like what's going on
what are they picketing it goes I see
cameramen I go there what cameraman
because you can't remain - to show your
Piketty I go there picketing the show
I'm about to go on [ __ ] yeah and I go
why didn't you tell me that he goes yeah
I didn't think it concern you I don't
not crossing a picket line you guys know
it's fine it's fine I don't know it's
not fine Mike
I grew up my father would kill me I
would never do that cross a picket line
and he goes no but they won't know we
can go around your back but aren't
they're gonna see the show man he was
not a no watch his show nobody but
they're like families they're gonna most
of these guys are divorced
I'm not doing that man I'm not bossing
the picket life it's like you gotta we
we shine yeah I go no no I'm not and I
and I Drive away and all the guys with
the picket signs you know cheering hey
way to go Adam buh buh buh buh so the
next day in the post
the New York Post it says Adam Sandler
won't cross picket line and then sandy
comes in with the article and guys look
what aunt did I tell you we'll get some
good fresh much more much more than said
when we come back cigarette
you